out to the place right now if you vote
Democrat I don't even want you around
this church you can get out
you get out you demon
you can get out you baby butchering
election Thief
you cannot be a Christian and vote
Democrat in this nation I don't care how
mad that makes you you get pissed off as
you want to you cannot be a Christian
and vote Democrat in this nation they
are God denying demons that Butcher
Babies and hate this nation
they hate this nation
get mad all you want to I don't care if
you stand I don't care if you throw
tomatoes praise God I'm about to throw a
microphone up in his house
CNN can eat my dirty socks you cannot be
a Democrat and a Christian you cannot
somebody say Amen
the rest of you get out
get out
get out in the name of Jesus I ain't
playing your stupid games
a bunch of devils
I'm sick of it
everyone talk about the insurrection
um
let me tell you something
you ain't seen the Insurrection yet
you keep on pushing our buttons you low
down sorry compromisers you God hating
communist America you'll find out what
an Insurrection is because we ain't
playing your garbage we ain't playing
your mess my Bible says that the Church
of the Living God is an institution that
the Gates of Hell shall not Prevail
against it and the Bible says that we'll
take it by force that's what the Bible
says
that's what the Bible says
speaking of weirdos and speaking of
weird Christian people who use religion
you gotta have you seen this so I can
clip Gabe you know Greg Locke is Holy oh
yeah he's uh he's been banned from
Twitter a couple times and then recently
came back and then I think within less
than 12 hours he was off the platform
again what do you mean like he opened a
new account kind of like Mike Lindell
did uh I forget if he opened a new
account but let me see uh well I'm sure
if I look for him he's I'm gonna he's
opening up Elon Musk soccer cat sock
puppet Russian bot accounts or something
this guy I thought like Mike Flynn and
Mike Lindell and Sidney Powell and Trump
are [ __ ] wacko dues and Weirdos this
[ __ ] this Greg Locke character
takes the goddamn cake and man does he
use blasphemy on religion actually
preach Antichrist type [ __ ] this here is
just I mean it's kind of hard to watch
y'all we're in the audience but man if
you're looking for some crazy because I
had a lot of people when I posted this
people like is this real is this guy
[ __ ] serious or this is this a like a
movie what is this but Greg Locke he
seems to be dead serious and really
honestly Gabe I bet this game has get
[ __ ] bodies buried in his crawl space
Oh
100 yeah
this guy has got something going on
there's no way you're saying [ __ ] like
this and you ain't got something going
on somewhere oh yeah let's listen to
Pastor dumb [ __ ] here Greg Locke
place right now if you
vote I don't even want you around this
church you can get out I wouldn't I I
wouldn't even be near near a church like
this and frankly I mean I already have a
problem with this but okay like we're
two seconds into this [ __ ] thing yeah
and where are you he's a he's a pastor
he's a priest right he he's he's he's a
man of God he's a man of Christ right
right right a man of Christ okay God
okay you know he's a pastor sorry let me
correct that he's a pastor uh in the
house of House of God he's there to
spread the word of God and why actually
think it's a tent of God because this
guy goes around it is actually a circus
it's actually a circus he does go set up
circumstance and he'd be he performs
these bigoted his like weird diets right
and pull up and spread the tent out and
he's got his little guitars back there
for the Christian band to spread their
HIPAA hypocrisy and their songs but
you've got a guy like this within the
first two seconds we watched he says if
you're Democrat I don't even want you
here right he's the opposite teachings
of Christ let's continue with the
insanity
you get out you demon you can get out
you baby butchering
election Thief
you cannot be a Christian and vote
Democrat in this nation I don't I
I mean it's almost funny I mean it is
kind of funny it is insane especially
when you're like oh man you baby you
baby eating uh election stealing
Democrats like dude have you not looked
at the Republican party oh my all of
these people week after week there is a
new story about some Republican
candidate or representative or you know
former politician who gets caught with
child porn sex trafficking being a
pedophile you know going to prison for
this this is the Republican Party he's
in a house at this circus he's in a
house of mirrors right now he's looking
at himself he's like you you you you you
you you you you you and he's just
looking at himself man I I would imagine
that this gay definitely definitely has
paid for abortions 100 is paper abortion
yeah yeah yeah without a doubt without a
doubt because he's calling Democrats
butchers he's definitely participated in
some sort of election fraud at some
point and I I still would say and I
don't have any proof of this but I would
say that this guy's got something he's
hiding like you said either either her
porn on his Hunter Biden laptop his copy
because they all got a copy everyone's
gotta everyone got a copy when they went
to their you know monthly meeting right
white replacement Theory you know so I
would bet on his thumb drive that has
Hunter Biden's copy of Hunter Biden's
laptop he's probably got some other [ __ ]
on there and he's probably got bodies
buried somewhere underneath the tent oh
my God damn man that makes you you get
pissed off as you want to you cannot be
a Christian and vote Democrats you gotta
hand it to him he's got a lot of
enthusiasm though yeah I mean he was
able to spit a lot of lies in that short
amount of time [ __ ] this guy is
committed to this [ __ ] I mean he is
really fully on committed to being not
christ-like it is astounding of how much
talent he has to be not Christian I
think the funniest thing there was how
uh Democrats were the America hating
group when it's the Republicans who are
the pro-putin group right which is weird
because you go back to Reagan when it's
like tear down that wall it's like man
how how quickly we have shifted to the
complete opposite of this Spectrum or
the Republican party is now pro-putin
and pro-genocide anti-life that's what
they are they love watching Putin commit
war crimes and killing innocent women
and children you know butchering
children I bet if you ask Greg Locke
about Putin oh he'd have all kinds of
wonderful things to say about it yeah
he's a wonderful leader he's a wonderful
man he really likes Trump and he's a
good Christian probably I don't care if
you stand I don't care if you throw
tomatoes praise God I'm about to throw a
microphone up in his house so Trump's
scared of tomatoes but griglock not
scared not scared he's not scared of
tomatoes he seems like he's like
possessed by a demon like somebody needs
to do an exorcism on Greg Locke and get
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] show is brewing
inside him out he either needs an
exorcism or a straight jacket one or the
other I mean I looked up who it was it
was uh it was Franklin Graham was the
person another preacher who said we
should pray for Putin get out in the
name of Jesus get out in the name of
Jesus now that that is some Blast for me
he's doing some high knees there he's a
kid out in the name with Jesus is that
the demon like trying to get I think I
think that was that was the that was the
deal he's trying to keep it in I don't
know maybe or here's another theory Greg
Locke actually took a demon against
their own will it's probably just put
him inside and that team is like I gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here
this demon is freaked the [ __ ] out by
Greg Locke he's like what kind of host
body is this [ __ ] Earthen vessel get
the [ __ ] out of here A bunch of devils
I'm sick of it everyone talk about the
Insurrection
now this is where this is where it goes
from absolute batshit crazy like nuttier
than [ __ ] squirrel turds to dangerous
this is the language the Maga King Mass
shooter this is the type of language
that Tucker Carlson is parroting JD
Vance is parroting Trump is parroting
because they're saying that people are
saying Mike Flynn is parroting these
messages that his [ __ ] Nazi rallies
and Nick Fuentes Marjorie Taylor green
Matt Getz Jim Jordan members of Congress
are parroting this language listen to
the dangerous [ __ ] talk he says and
how he uses Jesus to justify his
dangerous dog you ain't seen the
Insurrection yet is he talking to me
he's pointing to me he's yeah I'm like
yeah he's like he's he's pointing me who
is he talking to I don't know like I
heard a guy in the crowd say something
and he's like you ain't seen the
Insurrection
um
he's like he's like Josh Hawley when he
opened opens up Pornhub he's like is it
set the sound Holly man I think Josh
Hawley makes he like gets out that grunt
like um moan he's like
that's what he does
I don't know I don't know but he really
he Insurrection sandwich
let me tell you something yeah you ain't
seen the Insurrection yet no we watched
it we watched that the Gates of Hell
shall not Prevail against him and the
Bible says that we'll take it by four
hours that's what the Bible says oh and
he's using the Bible because his Bible
says you have to go now create and
commit insurrections and kill the devil
demon Democrats apparently this isn't in
the Bible people wonder how we get
homegrown terries white homegrown
terrorists you got to look at people
like Greg Locke Tucker Carlson Donald
Trump maybe that's who JD Vance thought
he was talking about he was like there
are three people that always get thrown
into the mix it's Donald Trump Tucker
Carlson and he heard Greg Locke all
right
JD Vance that the demon doesn't even
want to be in greglock the whole time
the team is trying to get the [ __ ] out
of there these people are competing for
the nuttiest squirrel turd that they
possibly can find they gave possibly can
be